901 emergency what are you reporting
um
yeah I think um I think my daughter's in
the best a strange 9-1-1 call leads to a
deadly officer-involved shooting outside
of a Home Depot in California
on May 27th California Highway Patrol
received a 9-1-1 call just before 4 pm
initially reporting on abduction sorry
your phone cut out there you said you
thought your daughter had been abducted
yeah my daughter's been affected do you
know who abducted her no I don't you
know where she is
I don't know where she is Sir why do you
think she's been abducted
because um I've been trying to get a
hold of him and then earlier I called
and some guy answered and just hung up
but after reporting the alleged
Abduction the caller identified as 47
year old Reuben Ramos said there would
soon be a shooting at a Home Depot in
Burbank I'm currently in Burbank and I'm
telling you right now it's going to be
true I have a gun too
I want people to
get I'm telling you enough I got a gun
I'm at the Home Depot
I'm at the Home Depot I'm about to get
off from if you're following me if you
don't get off here you know I have to
okay well I don't think that's a good
idea sir I'd prefer you didn't do that
I've been to Depot there's a lot of nice
people there I don't think they should
be shot
after this report the first dispatch
responder connects Ramos with burbank's
9-1-1 dispatch when the call begins
Ramos again references his daughter's
alleged abduction and you're saying that
you have a gun with you and you want to
sue people look I'm telling you right
now my daughter's been abducted and
she's being murdered as we speak
okay well CHP just said that you're at
Home Depot and said something about
shooting something to someone
I got people following me man I mean you
want me to do I gotta defend myself
okay so Reuben can you tell me if you're
at the Home Depot right now yes I'm at
the Home Depot right now in a car yes in
a van what color is your van silver
Ramos later tells dispatch he's armed
with a 25-caliber Beretta police
describe this as a compact pistol that
can be easily concealed what did you
tell CHP about shooting somebody
no no I I this is what I said I said
look I have people following me
and
um
they start shooting at me I'm gonna
start shooting back just minutes after
his initial call Burbank police officers
respond to the Home Depot and locate
Ramos hey buddy it's a police when First
Responders arrive Ramos is still on the
line with 9-1-1 the dispatcher can be
heard asking him to step out of the
vehicle with his hands up are you able
to step out of the van with their hands
up
no
he said no no I'm not
because we're trying to help you sir
I have a few officers there we want to
help you and talk to you about your
daughter
we're there to help you is there any way
you can exit the band with nothing in
your hands and your hands up
um
body camera video shows officers first
interacting with Ramos asking him to
turn away from them
it's in the car stay in the car
it's in the car
[Applause]
okay face away from me face away from me
bro don't do it face away from me
face away from me now face away from me
face away from me
okay face away from me I'm here to talk
to you buddy I'm here to talk to you
I want a gunpoint hey face away for me
face away from me
face away from me hey don't reach buddy
during this time officials speak to
Ramos in both English and Spanish put
your hands up for me
back
home just put your hands up for me
[Music]
hey all right let me see your other hand
I could help you but I need to see your
hand
just show me your hand man
what's your name
what is it
Spanish or English
Reuben you speak English
but Romo still refuses to remove his
right hand from his pocket
I'm here to help you okay
okay I want to help you but I can't help
you like this so this is what I need to
do I need to see your hands put your
hands up for me is anybody in the back
okay put your hands up for me where I
can see him I'm gonna I'm gonna help you
I promise you I'm gonna help you just
put your hands up for me eventually
Ramos follows officers directions
keep your hands out just like that all
right move it that's what we're gonna do
next prove it listen to me just put your
hands up for me put your hand both hands
up thank you all right turn around and
face away from me
move it turn around and face away for me
right there thank you are we ready do we
have a team
are we ready
got it yes
start walking back towards the sound of
my voice
lift up your shirt show me your
waistband
foreign
keep turning keep turning keep turning
keep turning for now
okay you're gonna start walking back now
towards the sound of my voice start
walking back
towards me
walk towards us just walk backwards it's
okay but after about one minute of this
Ramos begins to ignore officers commands
no not backwards backwards
officers again reference Ramos's
daughter and say they want to help find
her how old is your daughter Reuben 21
okay I need you to give me the address
where she's at
okay we're gonna we're gonna find her
through her cell phone how about that
can you give me her cell phone number
yes now Reuben in order for me to get
that I need you to come over here
towards us at this point officers
prepare a kinetic energy weapon used to
de-escalate the situation the gun
launches a sponge rather than bullet to
temporarily slow down a suspect
foreign
officials fire off the sponge and hit
Ramos in his upper torso after this they
say he aggressively reaches into his
pocket heads toward police and stands in
what officers refer to as a quote
shooting stance that's when officers
opened fire
again again
multiple recordings caught this same
moment from other angles all right man
Ruben I need you to calm down just bring
your hand back out
bringing your hand back out
get out of the way
Ruben let me see your hand
Reuben I can't help you if you have your
hand in your pocket man
yeah man
I need you to calm down bring your hand
back out breathe your hand back now
move it I can't help you grab your hands
in your pocket now
unfortunately okay
officials later recovered a knife from
the scene but never found the gun after
the shooting Ramos was taken to the
hospital where he was later pronounced
dead the officer involved shooting is
still under investigation by multiple
departments reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie